[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: How do you think
your life would be different
if you had access
to reliable energy?
MWANAIDI MWENDE:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: Mwanaidi Mwende
lives with her grandchildren
in a small village in Tanzania.
Every few days she
scours the land
around her home in
search of firewood,
which she uses to cook.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MWANAIDI MWENDE:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
LAURA LING: And do
your grandchildren
help you gather the wood?
MWANAIDI MWENDE:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: This is
one of the reasons why
so many girls are
not going to school
and getting an education.
It's because they're out here
helping their families gather
wood and other materials
that can be used as fuel.
And it's a very
clear example of how
the energy crisis impacts girls
disproportionately to boys.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MWANAIDI MWENDE:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
LAURA LING: Does that create a
lot of smoke inside the house?
MWANAIDI MWENDE:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
LAURA LING: Sometimes you
cry because of the smoke?
MWANAIDI MWENDE:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
LAURA LING: As
Mwanaidi was cooking,
you could hear her coughing
and her grandchildren
coughing around her.
And as she explained,
she has no other choice
but to cook this
way even though she
knows that it can cause harmful
long-term health issues.
What's incredible is that smoke
inhalation kills more people
worldwide than HIV
and malaria combined.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MWANAIDI MWENDE:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
LAURA LING: I hope
your dream comes true.
Please check out
this next video.
18-year-old Hussein Mwende
has lived his entire life
without ever having
electricity in his home.
HUSSEIN MWENDE:
I'm studying always
because I want to be a doctor.
Sometimes I have to
walk far distance
to find the place where the
electricity is available.
LAURA LING: To learn more
about energy poverty visit
ONE.org/energy.
Thanks for watching, and be sure
to subscribe to Seeker Stories.
[MUSIC PLAYING]